policing in america has been under
intense scrutiny since george floyd was
killed three months ago tomorrow
already the latest shooting of a black
man by police in kenosha wisconsin just
last night
led to the protests in the streets
concerns about racing policing go far
beyond the u.s
holly williams shows us how britain and
other european countries
are trying to deal with this issue if
you're black you're five times more
likely to be stopped by the police
you're more likely to be charged with a
criminal offence
that's the united kingdom he's
describing not the us
and this is michael fuller the most
senior black officer ever to have served
in the british police
now retired people of color are still
underrepresented in the british police
and fuller told us the racism he
encountered was often unspoken
they would give me the dirty jobs to do
delivering death messages where
relatives had died searching dead bodies
that had been pulled out of the river
ultimately i went for promotion and
managed to get through some 12 ranks
to get to the top of the police service
how difficult is it to tackle racism
within an organization well it's it's
very difficult
i was uncompromising uh in tackling
racism in that i would
call people out where i could but
sometimes the people being
racist were my bosses allegations of
police racism
cut across borders but when you compare
the us to the uk and europe
any interaction with the police is much
more likely to be deadly in america
the u.s police shot more than a thousand
people dead last year
compared with three in the uk and zero
in denmark and switzerland if you've got
a highly weaponized society you've got
the police highly weaponized
it is a disastrous cocktail british
police don't routinely
carry guns and under european human
rights law police are only allowed to
use
deadly force if it's absolutely
necessary
wait wait wait wait wait wait he didn't
do it of course nobody has
all the answers british police
apologized last month to bianca williams
a champion track athlete who was
handcuffed in front of her partner and
son
williams claims the incident was
racially motivated
police say it was a routine stop in
search in a high crime area
no one's going to be hurt just get out
the car you're going to be the team
overall though there's been a push to
make police officers better qualified
michael fuller told us in some european
countries
police training is in national academies
and takes
three years in contrast the us
has no national standards and in many
states training lasts
just a few months police officers have
tremendous power
they have tremendous discretion and what
you want is for the police officers to
use that discretion wisely
but in a way that demonstrates um
they're non-discriminatory and i think
the better
educated they are in these issues
the more likely they are to to make good
decisions
for cbs this morning holly williams
constable fuller making a lot of valid
points there